the free britney movement is picking up
steam once again
after a hearing was held in her
conservatorship case today
you know it has been 12 years since the
music superstar
lost control of basically everything
from her money
to her personal affairs
what do we want free breathing they feel
like maybe she's being confined or
something or held against her will
in some capacity spears family some
hollywood stars
and now her makeup artists are all
taking sides in the free britney
movement
spears former makeup guru posted he's
concerned
willing to help and referenced one music
video they worked on quote
sometimes you must scream and shout for
those who have no choice
in today's virtual hearing lawyers
discuss their conservatorship which is
still in effect until august 22nd
the next hearing is august 19. two weeks
ago a source close to the situation told
et
britt's virtual appearance had to be
scrapped because
four individuals who accessed the
court's video system
refused to leave the digital hearing
room
meanwhile on the gram brittany continues
to keep us entertained
head to toe hannah aggressive dancing
and this quote
go ahead judge me just remember to be
perfect the rest of your life
fans have long thought british using her
social media to send out secret
sos messages
[Music]
people are sometimes concerned about
what they
what they're seeing is brittany in
control right now of her social media
account or
yeah yeah she is
britney's brother brian recently shot
down rumors on a podcast
their dad also just spoke out calling
claims he's holding his 38 year old
daughter prisoner quote
a joke all these conspiracy theorists
don't know
anything it's up to the court of
california to decide what's best for my
daughter
a source tells e.t brittany wants her
mom to be in charge of her
conservatorship because
she feels her desires will be taken more
seriously she's been in this thing for
quite some time now
and you know all we can do is kind of
hope for the best